do it one last question I know we got a
rep to bit any last thoughts about rocky
level are we gonna see Rocky Balboa
again um right on the cusp where I
really have a good story it's whether
mmm yeah you know it's rocky you see the
thing is rocky outside I'm probably
don't agree I am going okay yeah that's
that's just nothing walking to there
okay but yeah that fist bump was yeah
that's true ciao but I have I have a
thing that it's politically we would say
vital right now and it's it's it's it's
that too is it's it's right on the edge
also it deals also with the foreign
country you know and what you've heard a
little bit about it and they want it
badly okay yeah and it's like oh should
I do this because rocky making a rocky
film and when people like Michael I want
to draw it Creed I go and think very
carefully about this yeah as you will
now have two years of no life right and
no guarantee is going to be a hit and if
you don't find I was blessed three times
with mister T Carl Weathers and all
these are so rare I cannot tell you John
how hard it is to find someone I can get
Big Bear huge man
but some of that visually you go he
doesn't have to say a word I get it I'm
terrified I wouldn't get in that range
or Carl Weathers there's no better film
fighter as a boxer than Carl Weathers
yeah it's if it's I have some 40 minutes
of him you know with eight millimeter
it's a miracle you know he's not a boxer
yeah it was I say thank God I found this
guy seriously